[Music]
all right good morning everyone welcome
back to our studio calm day two it's our
final day
my only announcement is if you are in a
row that's not very full and it looks
like you might need to squeeze more
people and feel free to sort of scooch
towards the middle and leave those empty
seats on the edges otherwise it's my
pleasure to introduce this morning's
keynote Selina I've been admiring her
from afar yes she and her PhD research
did this fascinating study of what
people actually do in Excel spreadsheets
and they needed a large body of
realistic spreadsheets for this and they
managed to have this great idea there's
there's a company you can read about
this is some Texas history called Enron
that had some some minor legal troubles
and as a result of the legal process all
of their emails were subpoenaed and
failing that and her group had the idea
that well there's probably a lot of
email attachments and so harvested
50,000 wild-caught Excel spreadsheets
out of this corpus that once they
reduced it to the unique spreadsheets
went down to 16,000 which also shows you
how much human behavior we have around
emailing duplicates to each other and
then they use that to do a great study
of what actually happens in spreadsheets
and she has interesting talks from the
years after that about how to use Excel
for programming that you can implement
mana as in Excel so you should watch
that one and so I'm just super
interested in the way she presents
things and how interested she is in
education and so that's for more recent
emphasis and she's taken up a new
appointment recently as associate
professor of computer science at Leiden
University so if a Lina I'm super
excited that we finally got you here and
we look forward to hearing you talk
about programming education
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good morning everyone so my name is
Selena I'm associate professor at Leiden
University I'm most on twitter my
twitter handle is my first name super
easy so if you want to talk about this
song maybe mention me so I can see
what's going on in the room afterwards
so this talk is about explicit direct
instruction in programming education
that sounds a bit technical so in order
to alternative title that we might use
it is one I stole from Greg Wilson of
our studio is how to teach programming
and other things that's what we're
really going to talk about how do we
teach programming because a lot of you
probably are also involved to some
extent in teaching maybe you teach your
kids but also junior colleagues maybe on
your team you want to get them up to
speed on your code base or libraries
that you're using people in your team so
lots of people are actually teachers or
teaching so I hope you get something out
of this book first mandatory audience
participation
who knows who said this everyone should
learn programming any guesses from the
audience
Steve Jobs Barack Obama well maybe I
think it's like every programmer ever
you are all guilty of this because we
love forgetting you're like we're going
so fast
everyone should learn programming but
this is it's fun but it also opens up a
super interesting question because what
is programming if I asked a bunch of
people in this room what is programming
I might get ten twenty a hundred
different answers what is programming it
might be very well that was for him to
me
isn't programming to you and we
programmers might not be the best people
to answer this question maybe you've
heard this story by David Foster Wallace
that I absolutely love about three fish
so this big fish he's swimming and he
burns into two tiny fish in the sea and
the big fish says hey folks how's the
water and the tiny fish say what's what
we programmers we are those tiny fish we
are so much swimming in the sea of
programming that it gets really really
hard for us to see we're in that sea to
understand that we're actually
influenced by this water of programming
as I call it so how did I came to think
about this it wasn't that one sunny
morning I woke up and I thought ah
today I'm going to ponder what
programming actually is there's a sort
of long backstory to this involving my
PhD work so let's go back to the year
2008 when I moved from Eindhoven where I
did my Master's a bachelor's degree to
Delft where I started a PhD in software
engineering this is the TU delft and my
research question for my PhD was to make
a DSL a domain-specific language for
finance that was actually my research
goal so my supervisor and me we
envisioned something like this a
programming language in which people in
finance bankers insures people like that
could express their business logic so it
said they didn't need programmers for
everything because there aren't a lot of
programmers and also it's very
empowering of course for people that
have no food programming degree or
experience to be able to make some small
things for their own needs so this is
what we envision to work on for four
years at my PhD and the first thing that
I did when I started is I did an
internship at a Dutch insurance company
I went there just to look around and to
see what are people actually doing in
industry because in my veterans I
master's degree I don't got lots of
experience of how stuff actually works
and my mental model of the world was
sort of this I'm not sure if they still
teach this in universities but when I
graduated this was how I saw the world
there are users and there are also
programmers they are entirely different
species with a wall between them they
have nothing to do with each other maybe
sometimes you know they converse a
little bit through the wall but in
general they're entirely different
people and the programmers program and
the users use this was my view of the
world fresh coming out of school into
this entrance
insurance company so I was going to Luke
and see what other programmers doing and
what are the users doing well turned out
it was more like this everyone in the
company was programming all of them the
programmers were programming but also
the other loan programmers people that
didn't have programming as a part of
their job Tyler or former role they were
also programming but they weren't
programming like this in a traditional
programming language of course they were
programming in spreadsheets this whole
insurance company was ran on
spreadsheets they had risk models of all
their assets and all different types of
countries where are we investing and it
was all run inside spreadsheets made by
a non programmer an end user program wow
that is weird because they told me in
school those years that normal people
the known programmers they needed our
programming help to make things because
they could only write things like
requirements and stuff they couldn't do
programming so Wow
so I went back to my supervisor I said
friends they don't need it
domain-specific language in finance they
have a domain-specific language in
finance and it's Excel whatever we're
going to work on in this four year PhD
project is never going to be as good as
spreadsheets it's never going to happen
spreadsheets and I really say this
without any irony spreadsheets are the
best programming system that has ever
existed in the history of mankind
spreadsheets are such a good programming
system that people can program without
knowing their programming let that sink
in for a bit imagine this happening for
another programming language and Maxon
imagine accidentally doing java
like hey I think I installed eclipse on
this laptop was super easy to do a
Windows and then I opened it up and I
immediately knew what to do and now I
build a risk management model my model
for our company just see how unlikely
that is with Java or or our C sharp or
probably even our Excel is such a good
programming model people just know what
to do and they can start doing it
immediately and it can add formulas and
pivot tables and VBA but initially it's
just so intuitive this moto away you get
live feedback from spreadsheet it's just
it's just a programming language so that
became model the motto of my PhD
dissertation spreadsheets our code we
should take spreadsheets seriously as a
programming paradigm because people are
running companies with it and people are
very very successful in billing stuff
with it but spreadsheets are not just
codes they're actually functional
programming as I showed in among method
that Daniel was talking about a formula
in a spreadsheet is guaranteed to be
side-effect free a formula this takes
input from other cells and then
calculate the results based upon those
cells so it has not never had side
effects it's pure functional programming
spreadsheets are also reactive
programming spreadsheet model works in
situated if you update a cell only the
cells that depend on that cell will be
updated and not a full recalculation of
the spreadsheet is needed so it's pure
functional reactive programming and
still 750 million people are able to use
it in an easy way like eat that Haskell
like wow so this became the motto of my
PhD dissertation and I wrote a bunch of
papers on it super cool we did smell the
section for spreadsheets refactoring for
smash spreadsheets we did clone
detection for spreadsheets all those
things that you would normally do once
you look at spreadsheets through the
lens of it being a programming language
and then hooray I became a PhD also I go
my dissertation
I wrote a book spreadsheets are code
awesome but you might wonder where is
this story about what is programming
coming in why is this lady bragging
about her teachers well first of all it
was lots of work but also there's a
point there's a point to this story
because this part of the story where the
things actually happened when it's true
they're facts but they're only that
they're only facts but there's also a
story of of the heart of what was I
feeling when I was doing all these
things and that's where the programming
stuff the what is programming stuff
comes in when I did this thought
previously someone said it looks like
Felina is doing therapy with an audience
that's true let's talk about feelings
for a while because feelings actually
matter alone so this is me super cool
going to programming conferences because
I really like speaking so even early in
my PhD I submitted talks to programming
conferences because I thought I have a
cool story and I just like being on
stage so why not submit some talks
around spreadsheets or code so going to
conferences and doing talks like this
and the people that are like it's not
real programming but I was willing
humans but their functional programming
and reactive programming and look I
build a monad I even to make my points
they'll take churring machine in
scratchy formulas only to show that it's
Turing complete I mean what else can I
do to convince them I have monad so I
have turned completeness it didn't
matter they were still like it's not
real programming and that went on for a
while and a while and a while
and I mean I'm laughing now but at that
point I was really sort of set who in
the audience has a PhD or is working on
one yeah a bunch so you know you like
you and your topic become this one thing
and if people say your topic is not real
or not world worthwile or anything then
it really hurts and I I really go now I
don't want to say depressed because I'm
not qualified to diagnose myself but at
least I was really really sad because
there was such a big difference between
how important I thought the stuff was
that I was working on and how other
people view it in my topic as most real
programming that that was definitely one
of the biggest reasons that I'm not
doing spreadsheet research anymore I was
just sick of this behavior of people
telling me my work wasn't wasn't real
and at this point I really thought this
is how adults treat each other I thought
well you know apparently if you're in
adults if you're in an adult
professional community people just make
[ __ ] to each other I just have to maybe
toughen up I don't know because
apparently it is like this it was only
until way later like let's go to 2015
when I realized that people can be nice
to each other it's sort of sad so I
joined a running club super cool so I
joined the running club and I'm Molly
grades are on they're like my fastest
half marathon it's 2 hours and 10
minutes I have friends in the running
club that do half marathon in like 1
hour 5 so they're literally twice as
quick as I am but no one in the running
community will ever say stuff like I'm
not a real runner never who in the
audience is a runner so we're we're the
worse you know runners we want to make
everyone runner so we're like Jehovah's
Witnesses like bingo have you heard the
happy news about running if I catch you
running through the bus I'll be like oh
do you like running do you want
don't erase segata what's your personal
record where the worst I mean we're the
best no one will ever say stuff like
you're not a real runner they don't say
[ __ ] like [ __ ] like oh you have Adidas
shoes but they have security
vulnerabilities
no one is like that everyone is super
nice to each other I'm like as I said
I'm the slowest and people root for me
they never say like give up on this
because you're not real running we've
been in a pub for one knowledge but
compare this to my experience in
programming only later I realize that it
doesn't have to be like this and it's
not just running I'm also a knitter I
really love missing and I missed the law
when I was a teenager but then I went to
university you know life happens so it
sort of gave up on knitting and then in
2016 I came back to nothing and I went
to a knitting Meetup which is a thing
super nice so I went there with my
old-fashioned straight needles but like
you go pass hand you down from your
mother from your grandparents straight
needles these apparently are out of
fashion people now use circular needles
I didn't know this come on - just meet
up everyone has different needles but me
oh my gosh this is going to be not real
missing they're going to be mean to me
for using this not the real skill but
they weren't they were super nice they
said oh you know we all use those
needles let let us show you how you do
is and this is what the benefits are but
in a super nice way not in a demeaning
way and that made me look back at my
experience in programming and I was like
why are they so mean I I don't I don't
have an answer for you it's maybe some
things are pulling their own layer like
why it's programming like that I don't
know but I didn't know all of that stuff
in 2012 so let's go back to 2012 I'm
like super sad i I really started hating
spreadsheets but I had just accepted a
position at Delft University as an
assistant professor and in my job
interview blatantly lied that I was
super excited about spreadsheets and
then for five years I was going to work
on that then also I got a grant proposal
so I had two pieces D students and a
postdoc ready to work on spreadsheets
but I wasn't feeling it so not much
great
luckily would really like safe my
happiness there was I ran into a bunch
of kids in a local community center in
Rotterdam I live and they needed a
programming teacher on Saturdays so it
was like okay I can do that let me teach
programming on Saturdays then at least I
have the feeling I knew week something
useful one day week and he'll figure out
work stuff later but at least I'll be
doing something useful so I picked up
that position at that school actually
still do that every Saturday and I'm
flying back after this talk so I'm in
time to teach tomorrow and it was it was
heartwarming it was really nice to see
kids coming in on Saturday to learn
programming but I didn't know anything
about teaching I had no clue about
teaching obviously I told a little bit
at a university but but this was
different I hadn't I just didn't know
how to approach it
I had no plan and I also wasn't
considering a plan I just thought let's
go there and we'll see what happens and
I think would happen in my brain not
consciously but subconsciously I started
thinking about how I was learning when I
was their age so this is me h10 behind
the computer yeah we had a computer and
I had this book of basic listings that I
got from the library and I just typed up
the basic listings in my computer for
hours and I didn't work because I had
syntax errors and then I fixed all of
those and then it's still dinner work
because I made indentation errors and
whatever type of mistakes but I'm in a
while it works and I had a game in basic
and that's sort of how I learned
programming and that's what I was
thinking of in that Saturday Club that
experience just giving kids sin sex
books basically asking them copy it and
then they will learn and notice the
absence of a teacher or an adult in this
story no one was teaching me programming
apart from maybe the book but there
wasn't another person so this was my
experience learning programming without
an adult or a teacher present and it's
not just me many people of my generation
that grew up in 80
learn programming alone learn
programming by themselves taught
themselves programming
a recent survey on stackoverflow among
hundreds of thousands of developers
stated that 80% of developers thought
themselves programming so this idea of
how to teach programming we don't know
how to teach programming as a community
we don't have a shared collective memory
of what a programming lesson looks like
other than us being alone within within
Commodore 64 or something like that and
and that does something to us as a
community that we lack this experience
of being in a programming class until
we're 18 in university and of course
then you are already shaped a bit as a
person so this left to this idea with me
but also with other people's just just
let kids explore the programming
language just give them the basic
listings well it's maybe scratch now our
Python but just give it to them and
they'll explore and they'll figure it
out and they'll pick it up naturally and
as I said it's really part of our
collective memory to learn in such a way
and you can also see that if you look at
books programming books for children so
I bought some books just went to the
books you bought some programming for
kids books and brought them to the
Saturday Club because once you started
looking on the things that are in there
it's sort of weird so it's in Dutch but
I translated it underneath so this says
the best part of programming is finding
mistakes yeah it's funny but it's also
interesting so notice what it doesn't
say it doesn't say the best part of
programming is making something creative
expression and it doesn't say the best
part of programming is being able to
find a well-paid job which actually
matters to many people it's a good
reason to go into programming I mean I
like having a house so that's your
reason it's interesting that one part of
programming the puzzly part is really
very stressed as the best part
this is in a similar vein says
programmers only learn from making
mistakes and there's some ambiguity also
in the description where it is can you
only learn from mistakes or if a mistake
happens the only thing you can do is
learn from it but what why why would I
only learn from making me sick why
wouldn't I learn from being told how to
do it in a proper way it seems to be so
much more efficient this is also nice
and these are books they're geared
towards a 9 year old so look at me I'm
an 8 9 year olds in a book shop picking
up Mook maybe I want to do horseback
riding pictures of horses passing them
oh they're so cute they're like unicorns
picking up inaudible maybe I'm
interested in something else programming
you will fail and also my nevermind I
mean it's sort of nice because at least
the people they scare away don't have to
go through the whole no real programming
writer I mean maybe that's veteran yet
but this is interesting why do we tell
this to kids I don't know because maybe
we're not a great community never be
afraid to mess around try out an
experiment really mean anything but the
next part of this is more interesting it
says break the rules if you're
programming it is important to break the
rules ok I guess but this is a book
about Python so let's let's go further a
few pages same book the coulomb goes
there the space goes there the space
needs to be in the right place otherwise
fightin will be very angry and it will
shout setbacks are more at you and you
have no clue what it means and end the
final stuff the colon goes there and the
quote goes there and every tangler
brackets go there but also break the
rules
get your [ __ ] together program what say
st. postman the most important thing
it's fun so it'll be frustrating you
have to break the rules but also not
break the rules because of the syntax
and if you're not having fun you're
doing it wrong because the most
important thing people is you should
have fun so you see this culture of
trying out exploring is very much in
everything we are and part of it that is
our experience part of that is our
culture so that's that's what I did as
well I bought those books I put them in
the group and I just have let kids
explore I can focus on concepts so I
said things like a loop is an important
concept that you need to know it is
about repetition stuff like that but I
didn't really thought like it really
really matters where the colon goes in
Python I didn't really talk about
because I was in this mindset of
exploring oh they'll figure it out
they'll get an error message and the
only thing they can do is learn from
that that was my my thinking and
surprisingly it didn't really go amazing
so I saw kids making some progress but
then eventually they go really really
frustrated and the nice thing about
teaching eight-year-olds versus
university students is that if an
eight-year-old is confused they will
tell you they will take this book and
dump it on the table and say I hate this
but it's a good experience as a teacher
because when students come into
University there they get scared about
saying they don't understand things so
dig I mean it's clear that if you give
the lecture to a big lecture hall wait
18 year old some of them will not get it
but they won't come up to you and hit
you with a book they'll go home and be
in their dorm and cry and be frustrated
or maybe drop out because they don't
understand so the type of feedback you
get from that group is very different
from the type of feedback good feedback
you get from younger kids so
I started to look into research that has
been done because I thought well people
must have tried this in research and
they did there's actually this nice
paper by Scaffidi and chambers that
looked at skill progressions in scratch
users so scratch is a visual programming
language very much aimed at young
children and they sampled children
throughout a number of projects and they
looked at okay what are the kids doing
so firstly they found very very high
dropout so kids register make a project
and then they quit that doesn't
necessarily have to mean something of
course maybe they decided a
horseback-riding was more freedom or
they immediately said I want to go to a
textual programming language like Python
or Java but they also found that kids
initially made some progress and then
their skill level sort of flattened that
they didn't explore new blocks new
concepts they had a few that worked for
them and then sort of stuck with that
and they also didn't get more efficient
so you can imagine that once they know a
few things and at least they would be
quicker added but also the efficiency
sort of flattened out and this very much
looks like my Saturday classroom
experience initially kids made some
progress but then I couldn't get them to
the next level and I didn't really know
why well I didn't know why because I
didn't know anything about teaching and
that's why I was really really bad at it
I don't know how this works in the US
but in the country I'm from if you want
to teach tiny humans in elementary
school you have to go to teacher school
for four years if you want to teach
medium sized humans in high school you
have to go to school for five years but
if you want to teach at a university you
get your PhD and 12 afternoons of
Bloom's taxonomy and then you're good to
go
this is really what happened to me I got
my PhD I didn't know anything about
teaching and I got into a tenure-track
position they like to shake it super
important to us so you should know a lot
about teaching
here's 12 afternoons of blooms good luck
so I really despite being a professional
educator in a well ranked University I
really didn't know a lot about teaching
so I was like issue fix this I should
know more
about how we teach things because
clearly this isn't going well and
there's an opportunity for me to improve
so one of the things I did is I wrapped
the Oxford Handbook of reading which
firstly stretches the definition of a
handbook a little bit it doesn't fit
into my hands but I have tiny hands
maybe but it's really really interesting
it's filled with all the things that
humankind knows about how children or
people read so I was like wow we're
programming we know nothing people in
linguistics research have figured out so
many detailed things about how people
read why are we doing that type of
experiments and one of the most
interesting things I read in Oxford
Handbook of reading is that how we
pronounce things actually matters a lot
so this is already very vivid in young
kids because one of the things you teach
children is if they start reading they
sound out the letters you're like oh
look that's a way of reading so
memorizing letters and words very much
goes to sounds we don't teach children
silent reading initially actually most
kids only pick up silent reading if
they're reading like a year and they
still sometimes if people have kids of
this age if they're six or seven they're
reading you can still see them they
don't like make a sound but they still
do that and this actually also sound
really matters for adults too so I'm a
scientist let's do an experiment
mandatory audience participation finally
experiment so this is what we're going
to do I'll show a sentence on the screen
once you reach the end of the sentence
reading it silently in your brain you
raise your hands so you get a sentence
if you're at the end awesome you raise
your hand there's there's a tiny caveat
though I won't show the sentence to you
in full
immediately you get the first part of
the sentence and then the second and
once you reach the end of the second
that's when you raise your hand so let's
try it perfect
are you ready for the real experiment
let's go here's another one so I didn't
knew any statistics but it seemed like
the second took you a bit longer and
this has repeatedly been shown in lots
of experiment that these type of
sentence take people longer to perceive
because clearly what's happening in your
brain is your reading I have a tear
because you're thinking it will be in my
eye that's more likely sound and then
you see my pens and you have to go back
RiRi pronounce the sentence in your
brain with there and then read the rest
you cannot not do that you cannot in
your brain here I have a tear I have a
tear in my pants you see I can even do
it so this has shown consistently across
proficient adult readers of English that
to a certain extent you always sound out
stuff if you're reading actually if you
want to do speed reading this is one of
the first things you have to stop doing
but it's very very hard
so how stuff sounds matters but I wasn't
necessarily impressed with this fact
even though it's a super cool fact I was
impressed with how well this was
measured that people set up an
experiment to figure out how to read
this type of synthesis and then they had
repeated that over different cultures my
net native language Dutch you wouldn't
be able to do this because we don't have
two letters that change sound but we
have other things that could confuse in
terms of mispronunciations but they
haven't repeated this type of
experiments and they have real solid
knowledge of how people read things like
we have no solid understanding of how
people read source code for example no
one has done similar experiment
this this solids and this repeated about
reading short code so I was like wow we
know nothing there's so much more to
explore in programming but the second
thing I got from this book is we like
fights in programming education there's
very much a monoculture and of course I
don't mean a real fight I mean some
pedagogical diversity in other fields
like math and language there are
different streams different beliefs from
people of how to teach and they argue
about that usually in a polite way not
in a urinals real teaching way but in a
more solid way and one of these debates
you might be aware of it is called
phonics versus whole language these are
two streams in reading education so
phonics is like I just said this this
sounding out II read you start with the
basic letters and then words and then
sentences and this is how you build up
an understanding of children of letters
and words you also have the whole
language approach and the whole language
of process approaches no language is not
about technical skills language is about
communication so you shouldn't teach
people individual letters because that
technical skill is going to disengage
them from reading you should just give
them censuses and contacts and that's
the better way to teach there was also
in the US in the 80s you might be aware
of this something called the mat Wars
where in a similar vein people were
discussing how to teach math so some
people said well the way you teach math
is you explained kids what to do then
they do it in a whole bunch of times and
then they get it on the other side of
the aisle you had no math is about
finding the truth and beauty so you
shouldn't bore people with memorization
you should give them problems to explore
exploration those are two sides of two
opinions of teaching and we really have
ever had
that pedagogical debate where we're like
but wait how do we even teach this it
just hasn't happened for programming and
probably that's because of this
philosophy that were not really aware of
so Allen Blackwell really interesting
scientists from the UK he says that
technology is covert philosophy really
interesting interesting statement it
means something like if someone has
built a piece of technology from that
you can see what the people believe
about the world like people that have
built something like Twitter they might
say it's neutral but there are beliefs
that free speech is maybe more important
than other things you can see it from
how they build that system and in a
similar way I think education is also
covert philosophy you can learn a lot
about the things people believe from the
way they teach there's a lot to learn
about our culture from the way we teach
so there's not just the water of
programming but there's also the water
of teaching programming and we are so
much in this one sight water that we
don't really even really lies how weird
it is and there's some history in our
field many people aren't aware of that
has also contributed to that philosophy
so who knows who this is the creator of
logo yes Seymour Papert so he's kind of
well known in our community he created
logo which was the first programming
language for children but he came rooted
in a certain philosophy he actually
studied with a guy called Jean Piaget
one of the most important psychologists
of the previous century and he's the
founder of a thing called constructivism
and constructivism means the basic idea
there's a lot to it but the basic idea
is that I cannot put knowledge into your
brain the only way you can learn
something is if you construct reality in
your own brain and piaj has said about
pop art nobody understands my work
better than Seymour he was very much
influenced by this idea of you can old
you should not teach people things they
should explore
so for example he said things like by
explaining something to someone you take
away the opportunity for a child to
discover it and this being a bad thing
that you take away this opportunity and
then you see how weird this is if you
compare this to other things so imagine
you have a kid or a kid you care for
they want to learn the guitar or tennis
would you buy them a guitar and say hey
I'm not going to tell you anything
because that will just ruin the surprise
for you so you just figure out you know
strings courts finger placement you just
figure it out you'll be fine it'll be
fun this way I'll be in my room or like
tennis do you really want kids to figure
out what is it what is a back head and a
forehand and how do you rip the thing
most efficiently it doesn't make any
sense so then you see how weird it is
and how very much that philosophy of
Peoria and popper still is visible in
those programming books I showed in the
beginning of my lecture because in this
situation will be like we get am a tutor
in a club and that form of teaching is
actually very common and very aligned
with the left hand side of the argument
with phonics and with explanation and
practice in all sort of things sports
music language math we have focused on
just explaining stuff to kids so warning
some controversy ahead because some
people really still very much buy into
this philosophy but across fields it's
been very very clear that this left hand
side instruction phonics explaining is
just better it's just better than
exploration there's this paper by a
Dutch psychologist called Paul Kirchner
and some other people why minimal
guidance doesn't work and it summarizes
a long list of studies across fields
saying you should just explain stuff to
kids there's this other paper actually
by sweller and Cooper that
compared to groups of children half of
the group gods a worked example so the
teacher said this is what you do and you
just do you just do the steps and the
other group of kids got a more
traditional maybe in some places
equation they say this is the equation
you have to solve it for a and they
didn't know how to do it and they
compared the children how well they did
and this left group first group did way
better they did the solutions in
one-fifth of the time of the other group
so not 20% less in the 20% of the time
and they also did better on new programs
new problems so it wasn't that they
could just solve the thing they've
practiced if you then gave them similar
assignments they still do well and this
makes lots and lots of sense if you know
a little bit about short-term memory so
here's another mandatory audience
participation session I'm going to put
let's say a thousand dollars on the
table if you can remember this tiny
snippet of things I'll put in front of
you for a few seconds no pictures
and it was hard right no one got it I'm
not really betting
next one so the next one is interesting
I'm not I wouldn't bet $1,000 but I
would bet a hundred that this is still
pretty hard next one I wouldn't bet any
money on this one that's super easy
right but it was the same length the
same number of things the same variety
and things and still this was super easy
to do that's because our shirts on
short-term memory can only hold seven
plus or minus two items and actually you
might be aware of this study newer
research said it's now four items so
there's very very limited room in our
brain to store things and this why is
this so easy because you just store
three things you know you don't store
the individual letters you don't store
the individual word words you store the
concepts you think of a cat and then of
luvs and of cake and it makes sense and
if you think about this you have room
left in your brain you can read this
memorize it and think oh I miss my cat's
oh I would love some cake maybe there
will be cake at the coffee break later
while still also remembering these three
things you can do that so that has to do
with something called cognitive loads if
I would really bet you to remember this
then if you were to try memorizing it
you you get this fullness in your brain
right you're like oh it's an awl with
adults and a long stripe and like a
sigma but reverse you feel your brain
getting fuller and that fullness is
called cognitive loads and that's the
reason that this one group the left
group does better and in all sort of
similar experiments because the other
group had a too high of a cognitive
loads they're solving the problem but I
have to think of many things like what
approach am I going to take and Oh what
is that technique again and the brain
gets so full that there's no more room
to actually store the memory of what
they were doing so I think the biggest
if you just remember one thing from my
focus you don't become an expert by
doing expert things that's what these
studies have shown and that's the
misconception that we have in
programming and to a certain extent also
in math we think that if we want kids to
be problem solvers we give them problems
to solve if we want kids to be
programmers we give them programs to
program but it doesn't work like this if
you want kids to be problem solvers you
have to teach them to memorize a load of
strategies for problem solving or a lot
of strategies for programming that's how
they memorize and then once they see a
problem their long-term memory is filled
with all of the approach these
approaches they can then use again think
of other things you want to learn like
running the worst way to prepare for a
marathon is to run a marathon every day
everyone gets that what do you do well
you do bench presses and sit-ups and
interval training you do all these other
things that help you do a marathon
same with playing the violin if you want
to learn some sort of Beethoven thing
you're not going to start by doing
exactly that thing know you'll do chords
and finger placement and stuff like that
so you build up little pieces of
knowledge such that you can achieve
bigger things so you don't become an
expert by doing extra things and in
programming we still very much believe
that so my goal of this is to start a
fight well mode I fight but a debates
about pedagogy of programming because
this side this whole language inquiry
exploration part is basically the only
side that we have heard from in
programming partly stemming from poppers
and logo partly coming from the way we
were taught in the 80s that we have that
side covered but now I want to explore
the other side how would direct
instruction look like for programming
what are those tiny things that we can
do to help kids become programmers what
are the interval trainings and the bench
freshers and then the cords of
programming we've been exploring this
actually at my research group in Leiden
and one of the cool
that we've done probably the most
exciting thing maybe next to the unknown
case that I worked on is this idea that
we can teach kids to say syntax to
vocalize syntax allowed remember that
sound really meadow matters for English
and other languages so probably code
sounds also matter or lots and we then
experiment with some offices and we ask
them to speak a line of code allowed
simple things like an assignment we got
all sorts of things X is 5 x equals 5 X
gets 5 set X to 5 assign 5 to X all
sensible things but apparently kids and
we repeated it was experts same story we
don't have a shared mental model of how
to read code in our hands and probably
based on those stuff we know from
linguistics this is going to hamper our
understanding and something interesting
that we didn't think about so we thought
it was going to be confusing but these
were Dutch children and there were all
these extra things that came into play
that we didn't think of for example this
letter in English is called I I as
inside but in Dutch my native language
in a native language of these kids we
say it as if he is in creep so once
children started reading these code
snippets they got confusing information
because the teacher would often say for
I in range because your brain gets in
the English mode but sometimes also
conversationally the teacher would say
oh what variable oh it's it's eat
because they would be speaking in Dutch
at that point so we have kids vocalize
this get snippet as for I in range print
e same constant sedation can wonder have
they really understood so one of the
things that we're working on this this
model of we need consistent vocalization
for source code such that children can
repeat it and memorize it better we did
a super cool study where we had a group
of kids repeating source code after us
for I in range very much like you would
do the tables of multiplication as well
1 times 3 is
dream and we found out it actually helps
we had two groups one group red code
allowed every lesson and we had a
control group that didn't do that we
would vocalize the code but we didn't
have this group exercise of vocalizing
everything and we found out that this
first group just does a lot better on
syntax exercises and we're about to
publish a paper on that and it's so cool
because if I give presentations about
this research to elementary school
teachers that I sometimes do they look
at me like wow it's 2019 and you've just
figured out that having children read
something aloud works well done
slow clap very impressive telly did
no-one ever think of this we all go to
school saying 1 times true you know how
often have you done that how often were
you made to read aloud letters when you
were learning and yet to the best of our
knowledge we're the first one to
actually try this on source code and
surprise surprise it actually worked so
no one was really surprised so that's
one of the things we're doing another
thing that we're doing is teaching
children and and students as well
explicit reading strategies so here's a
snippet from a linguistics paper that
says here are a few strategies that you
can use to read natural language
so we're strategy is like looking at
pictures skipping parts of the text that
you think are important they explain
children how to read natural language if
they are just learning and then they
test them they say what strategy have
you used or they say here's some natural
language use this specific strategy and
then try to figure out what it means we
don't do any of this for source code I
have undergrads in programming classes
you give them a piece of source code to
read and they just start at the
beginning and why wouldn't they we've
never told them what is a good strategy
for reading code things experts do
because they fix it up naturally like
look at all the methods or look at all
the fields or cool apps something some
ideas can collapse everything and
you just look at the signatures they
have no strategies because they weren't
taught strategies and we did a study
actually this is still research in
progress but we had these were
undergrads some students we explain
strategies we practice strategies with
them in class and we had a control group
that were taught in a more traditional
way so very much aimed at creating
programs and not really reading a lot
surprise surprise guess not the group
where we explicitly explain reading
strategies for source code they did
better this is as I said still research
in progress and something else that were
really excited about is assessment in
programming classes especially in
programming clubs for kids assessment
plays no role because they're very much
ran by these people that buy into the
exploratory learning style so things
like this having a tiny test saying this
is in touch which one is a variable
circle the right block or which one sets
a variable to zero doing these things in
code clubs is very much against what
they believe in so that's something
we're exploring how can we get
assessments into out of school code
clubs no because we want to give gift
kids grades but we because we want to
help teachers understand what is the
level that the children are at are they
at this flat skill level where they
maybe need a little bit of help to jump
to the new level so this is also
something we're exploring should you run
a code club on the side then please send
me an email or tweet because we'd be
really interested if you want to try
this stuff out with us so like
everywhere there are also haters in my
new fields sadly because haters are
everywhere except from knitting and
running
so now I give this dog now I don't feel
the conference's because I am just like
the owner stage and I tell people this
story and they're like but it doesn't
seem fun and one of the other comes with
side percent seems like it's a guy
they're often guys point is a failure in
my face almost saying you're making it
like school school school is not
terrible at dishing people things I
don't know it's cool bad I I work at a
school calm down
but actually the nice thing is research
says this doesn't matter stuff doesn't
have to be fun to actually be and to be
useful like I go to this running club
every Monday and I do 50 pushups do you
think that's fun no being on my couch
watching Netflix and eating potato chips
is fun that is pain its horror I dread
it but I know it makes me better and
that's why I do it and the same is true
for kids people think especially
educators many educators and outside of
school clubs think that if kids are just
motivated they will get skills if they
just want to learn and then they will
get better but it's not true
it's actually very often the other way
around kids that are skills will be
motivated and specifically like am i
running exercise if I feel I'm making
progress
this also holds for kids if they feel
they're learning even if it's painful
then they will be motivated to learn
more so what is actually kind of
demotivating is just having them have
fun I'm being stuck at a certain skill
level because if they don't feel they're
making progress
they will not be motivated so that's it
that's everything I wanted to share
before we end the session
let me summarize my entire talk and like
one minute because I know some people
came in late or they're just awake and
also I speak a bit quickly so let me
give you a second chance to get the gist
of everything first of all don't be this
people
I know probably in this community it
I've been at the conference since
Tuesday it's really friendly I don't
think most of you need this advice but
still they'll be aware of it and if you
hear people do it even if it's not you
like try to step in and let's just try
not to be or allow these people in so
what I've been talking about is the way
we teach programming which has been very
influenced by streams of belief and
often influenced by the lack of our
community of a shared memory of how a
programming lesson looks like that
impedes us from teaching and this
culture is very valid in books and
lessons they're very much emphasized
problem-solving and making fun and
programming should be enjoyable and
puzzly and this comes to a certain
extent also from the history of
programming education that many people
aren't aware of is very very tied to a
specific methodology of teaching sadly
this methodology just has shown in other
fields consistently to not work as well
as explanation and practice so my my new
goal in life is to help figure
programming out how could direct
instruction looks like what are the tiny
building blocks that we can give
children so they advance and they're not
swimming and confused but they can feel
they're making progress and thus be
really motivated the end so if you want
to check out more of my work i'm on
twitter and i have a website where all
my research is shared all my papers are
there open access and always accompanied
by a blog post that also educators could
easily understand so no too technical
little p-values there if you like
listening to me you might also want to
check out a post cast I host it's called
se radio we have five episodes every
month interviewing people in the
software engineering field
we don't do Q&A but there's one question
I always get so I will answer it
have you had thrown these slides the
answer is yes I made them with my Apple
pencil
and an app called good notes all by hand
apart from some technology and then I
wouldn't want to end before thanking
some people that worked on this with me
mainly grad students and postdocs in my
lab and the final Greg if you know him
because he's Greg Wilson and he's been
just such an inspiration thank you
[Music]